the humanitarian situation in Sudan has
been deteriorating rapidly since
violence broke out 12 days ago people
say they're running out of food water
and Medicine
we're really suffering grain meals are
closed and we cannot grind our stock of
wheat most basic Commodities are absent
and if they are available the prices are
very high
living conditions are very dire for
everyone prices have soared a means of
transportation are almost gone people
are really suffering
it's not only Sudanese these are Hunger
refugees fled persecution in Myanmar
they now find themselves in the middle
of another conflict
because here situation is very bad very
heavy fighting for two groups so we are
near the school anyway I need to save
some some people have managed to escape
a boat carrying 1600 citizens of 50
countries has docked in Jetta and Saudi
Arabia and the United Nations says at
least 20 000 people have arrived in Chad
the number of those fleeing Sudan is
expected to reach up to 200 000 in the
coming days as more and more people try
to find a way out those who remain
behind say it's not only the
deteriorating humanitarian conditions
they're worried about but also the
security situation in the capital
at the weekend inmates escaped from
Cobra prison in the capital A
high-profile detainee who served in
former president omarel bashir's
government announced he had left the
prison Ahmed harun is wanted by the
international criminal court on charges
of crimes against humanity in Darfur the
Army says Bashir is being held in a
military Hospital
the rapid support forces posted a video
on social media saying it had taken over
a major oil refinery and power plant
about 70 kilometers from Horton we are
in full control of the refinery We
Believe In Action not empty words this
is not the time for their nonsense we
control the majority of the country
north south east and west we have 200
control over Sudan
despite this the Army says it's in
control
it is the pride of the Sudanese Army
that we had not touched a single
facility or any infrastructure it is the
rapid support forces that destroyed them
this war will come to an end very soon
and you will listen to the final
statement all of the main facilities are
operational and in order including the
electricity and water supplies
the United Nations says there is no sign
the warring parties are ready to
negotiate and has warned of further
suffering as long as the fighting
continues Heber Morgan Al Jazeera
cartoon
we're leaving Khartoum is a difficult
and dangerous undertaking the UK has
flown some people out from a military
air base north of cartoons but it can
take several hours to travel the 20
kilometers from the capital to the Wadi
side in the base
Saudi Arabia and India are among the
countries that have evacuated people
from Port Sudan some 850 kilometers or a
13-hour Drive East of katum some are
making the treacherous Journey to the
border with Egypt that's about a
thousand kilometers from the capital
While others are taken even longer route
about 1500 kilometers West to the border
with Chad
Muhammad Idris is near the chanced
onboarder where Sudanese refugees are
fleeing into their neighboring country
the refugees mainly women and children
crossed over from Sudan's therefore area
into this part of Chad the United
Nations High Commissioner for refugees
say they have registered more than 4 000
refugees and could run alone and there
are hundreds and hundreds more who are
yet to be registered and they hope to
accomplish that in the past in the next
few days now what the the situation here
in this particular Camp is desperate
none of the refugees have any permanent
structure over their head there are no
structures no tents and some of them are
virtually living under trees and they're
telling us that the situation here is
desperate a lot of them say they haven't
eaten over the past few days now
on this particular day the United
Nations and its agencies deployed to
this particular area to see the
situation for itself it brought along
tons and tons of food items to be
distributed to the refugees and what let
me show you in particular what's there
for for them now these are sacks of
grains rice as well as oil that will be
distributed to the refugees all across
this particular region what is not clear
is what happens to the other refugees
who number in their hundreds who are yet
to be registered by the United Nations
uh agencies or relief agencies here now
when we plan the camera to this site
this particular family has just received
its own share of grains we can see it's
like that's wheat and a few uh stuff
like cooking oil palm oil grounded oil
some flour that could help the family
get along until such a time that things
improve in this particular camp now the
United the one foot program is telling
Al Jazeera that they have deployed uh a
lot of food items that will cater for
only 20 000 people and the situation
right now in this Camp is that they are
expecting more than 20 000 people in the
days to come the United Nations is
projected between 120 000 to up to 200
000 people crossing from Sudan into this
part of child which means that the
United Nations and its agencies and
other relief agencies need to step step
up their act in order to cater for these
refugees